c'est une situation qui fait rêver de
nombreux européens
les danois vont pouvoir profiter des
salles de cinéma des salles de gym ou
encore des salles de spectacles dès
aujourd'hui des lieux qui rejoignent les
bars et restaurants déjà ouvert depuis
le 21 avril dernier
b réouverture liée à une bonne situation
épidémiologique mais également par la
mise en place du passeport sanitaire
danois le corona passe pour accéder à
ces lieux publics
les danois doivent justifier d'un test
négatif de -2 72 heures ou d'une
vaccination ou encore d'une guérison
récente du covin 19 une contrainte pour
l'instant accepté par une majeure partie
de la population et des commerçants
mais la lenteur du rythme de vaccination
oblige des milliers de danois à se faire
tester régulièrement
conséquence les centres de tests sont
pris d'assaut
et on estime qu'un citoyen sur dix se
fait tester chaque jour cinq fois plus
qu'en france un pas solitaire loin
d'être acceptée par tous deux fois par
mois le mouvement des men in black
littéralement les hommes en noir
manifestent contre les mesures de
restriction en mouvement qui réunit
plusieurs centaines de personnes autre
sujet d'inquiétude récurrents la
protection des données médicales et les
inégalités face aux passeports
sanitaires si vous avez besoin d'un test
et que vous êtes handicapé ou que vous
n'avez pas de moyen de transport ou que
vous habitez en endroits reculés ou que
vous êtes sdf il y a plein de raisons
pour lesquelles certains pourrait ne pas
avoir accès au corona passe et cela va
créer des inégalités des oppositions que
devront prendre en compte les pays qui
souhaitent lancer leur propre passeport
sanitaire copenhague a d'ores et déjà
annoncé que le dispositif serait
réévalué cet été la france devrait
officiellement lancé le sien en juin
prochain
[Musique]